sony pictures entertainment is reeling
from what may be the biggest and most
devastating computer hacking in
hollywood's history hackers attacked in
waves
first crippling sony's internal systems
then leaking five sony movies online
today the u.s government pointed the
finger of blame directly at north korea
for the devastating cyber attack against
sony pictures sony pulling the plug on
the interview
saying it will not show the
controversial comedy about an
assassination attempt on north korea's
leader
the sony pictures hacking was taken
very seriously because it was an attack
on the
free world what we have been building
in terms of our civilization and our
freedom and our ability to
exchange information freely have been
disrupted by a country that we knew very
little about
north korea has reportedly made attempts
to steal covert 19
vaccine technology by hacking
pharmaceutical giant pfizer
the justice department has charged three
north korean hackers over a wide-ranging
scheme
that included the attempt theft of
billions of dollars for multiple
companies
despite so many attacks blamed on north
korea
there was not much known about the
people behind the hacking
attacks and my aim was
to reveal who these people are what they
are like what their
operations are like and on what their
dreams and fears were
my name is sam kim i'm a reporter for
bloomberg news
and i wrote a story for business week
about north korean hackers
my story is about people who are sent
from north korea
to countries like china to hack for the
regime
spy on enemies and make money
north korea's cyber abilities began
about in the 1970s with a lot of
students going to
countries like russia china and even
east germany to learn coding was aimed
at improving the productivity of
factories at home
but in some time in the 1980s and 1990s
the current leader kim jong-un's father
kim jong-il thought that it would be a
good idea to develop
a team an army of people who could
hack for north korea's military
so they began this team of basically
hackers who would spy for
the north korean regime and also go out
there
and make hard currency for the regime
i think kim jong-un takes the hacking
ability
more seriously than his father he also
enjoys
a bit of tech savviness as well you know
he's often shown
traveling on his airplane where
on the desk there's a mac computer
he understands the importance of
computers he understands
the importance of employing technology
to improve productivity
of his economy
north korea is an isolated country
with its economy pretty much dilapidated
nowadays it's been under increasing
pressure and sanctions from the u.s and
the international community basically it
does not have the resources and
money to build the kind of conventional
weapons that other countries
are able to build so what happens is
north
nuclear
concentrates its resources on building
nuclear arms
and missiles which experts call
basically
a symmetrical weapons it's the kind of
weapons that gives
north korea an instant edge
think of cyber hacking abilities in that
context
it doesn't cost that much money but if
you have the right people
and if you have the right training you
are able to cultivate
an army of people who are able to
penetrate into computer systems of other
countries
and that's what north korea is after
but if you consider the fact that there
are only about a thousand ip addresses
in north korea available
and many of them are basically loan from
chinese communications companies
you can kind of tell why north korea is
willing to send
its hackers abroad rather than operate
from within
what's the matter with operating from
within well
first of all it would mean that a lot of
information
would have to be coming in from the
outside world
which could risk exposing the government
and the people to whatever truth there
might be
about them so they're sending their
trained
hackers to china and other countries
where
access to information is better but at
the same time because
these are allies and also because they
have their diplomats stationed
in countries like these like china
they're able to
regulate and control these hackers
better
but formally north korea denies engaging
in hacking
and describes accusations to that effect
as enemy propaganda
it took me at least half a year to track
down these people
it felt like a wild goose chase in the
beginning
because see a lot of the people like
these
are protected by the government
in south korea but at the end
i was able to find a person who had
pretty extensive ties to the north
korean
defective community here and then i was
also
able to gain access to the people who
had actually
done programming hacking from north
korea before coming to south korea
zhang is one of them
jung actually is not a real name i knew
before meeting zhong that he was in his
late 30s
but when i actually met him he looked at
least a decade older
he wouldn't open up i mean it took me i
think at least an
hour to make sure that he would trust me
enough that he would
share with me his life story
[Music]
when he was first sent to china he was a
student studying computer science at a
university
near the border with north korea and he
came back
and realized that there was a lot more
to do in china because he had more
access to information
and he asked that he'd be sent back to
china
and there was also recruitment going on
for people who would actually
do coding officially but really hacking
for north korea so he applied and he got
the job
once he got to the border he crossed by
foot and from there
he took a bus and then when he arrived
at the station that he would spend years
in later
he learned that that three-story
building
in the heart of the city was actually
provided
for free actually by a chinese man
who had business ties in north korea
there were actually two other people
that i had met
they all said that they gone to this
freelance website for programmers
and clients from around the world would
come
and give them orders give them jobs to
do
some of the jobs given to zhang were
cracking open
commercially successful anti-virus
programs
and once he was able to open that up he
replicated that program
into another product which his client
would
repackage as a whole different product
to be sold to other people he also
created
what we now call bots there are very
popular online games
including lineage he would create
a buff that would just roam around
without
any supervision from the user
and basically trade items with other
users
on that game he would throw that bot on
lineage and sell it for
almost a hundred dollars another
defector said the money from clients was
wired primarily via paypal
to accounts controlled by minders
because they were the only ones with
access to legitimate bank accounts
john had to make at least a hundred
thousand dollars a year
and he doesn't get to keep most of it
actually most of the money goes the
minders
to the north korean regime but if you
don't meet the quota
and the minders will make sure that
they'll put enough pressure on you
and if that happens repeatedly you will
face the
growing odds of being sent back home
among the three people that i spoke to
there's a common thing that they all
tell me which is that
on every saturday they have to do this
propaganda session which
is basically about gathering all the
hackers together
into a room and they have to recite
whatever messages whatever lines come
from
pyongyang about the kin family about
socialism
if you're especially someone who with a
free set of mind
that's stressful one person actually was
really stressed out
what he heard about north korea once he
was in china
during the propaganda sessions he just
couldn't take
[Music]
john was a senior member of the unit
that he belonged to
and he was good at chinese as well
whenever
a senior north korean official came from
north korea
to check on the hacking units in china
john would accompany that official he
doesn't
provide me details but he calls it
unsavory incident that happened between
him
and an official that he was traveling
with
and that altercation prompted him
to defect but
there was no one that he could turn to
after the facting
he would in disguise roam around china
he told me that he actually enjoyed it
he actually enjoyed the freedom of
you know not being known to anybody just
roaming around
a country that was huge
how did he make the money that he needed
to carry on
he did the same thing he did you know at
the north korean unit he he would take
orders he would reverse engineer
software
to make money but at one point
he said he was just sick and tired of it
all of a sudden he just
he wanted to find a place where where he
could just settle down
and he contacted south korean
authorities
now he lives in korea he met a woman
here
you know last time i checked they had a
baby
he worked for a software company
ironically
an anti-virus company
what keeps coming up in my head
even long after i spoke to these people
is there was one common thing about them
which was the sense of disillusionment
once they had
access to outside information once they
were able to
freely roam in the internet
there was a spark
and once they realized that there is a
discrepancy between what they think is
really happening and
what north korea is telling them every
saturday morning
that's when the spark gets bigger
[Music]
the little fire is what
eventually drives them to decide to
leave
even if it takes a huge risk on their
[Applause]
lives
[Music]
you